>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Gregory Lukow: Good
morning, everybody.
[ Inaudible Conversations ]
Good morning.
I have been given instructions
by Josh Shepperd to
split the difference.
We're not starting at 8:30 so that
we can let as many of you gather
in this room as possible.
But he said, "Do start at 8:45."
So I am saluting Josh
Shepperd and starting.
Good morning.
My name is Gregory Lukow.
I am Chief of the Library
of Congress's National
Audio-Visual Conservation Center,
headquartered at the Library's
Packard Campus in Culpepper,
Virginia, about 75
miles southwest of here,
and still encompassing all the
activities, traditional activities,
of the Library's Motion
Picture and Broadcasting
and Recorded South Division.
Welcome to the Montpelier
Room of the Madison Building.
There's a connection there.
In fact, if you go down into
the lobby you'll see a statue
in a hallway of James Madison
which is the federal
government's official recognition
of our fourth President,
as is this building.
So, welcome to the
Library of Congress.
You're actually going
to get two welcomes
for the price of one this morning.
My colleague, Eugene Flanagan,
will be talking about all
of the national planning
and coordination activities
that the Library does on behalf
of preservation activities,
including radio.
And I'll be focusing a little
bit more on the internal work
that the Library does in the
domain that he'll be talking
about here today and tomorrow.
The National Audio-Visual
Conservation Center if part
of the Library Services Unit
of the Library of Congress.
It's the largest unit in
the Library of Congress.
About 1500 people, which provides
all the National Library services
of the Library of Congress.
We're -- the Preservation Center
in Culpepper's probably
the largest single division
of the 50-some divisions
within Library Services
within the Library of Congress.
And we're one of the few here that
works in all three of the ways
in which any archive, library,
or museum can structure itself.
We collect by format.
We serve by function,
not only acquisition
and cataloging, but
also preservation.
And we collect and provide
access and focus on subject.
In this case, the history of radio,
its creators, its industries.
That's all what we do
at the Packard Campus.
We acquire, we catalog and
describe, we store, we preserve,
we have three preservational
laboratories in Culpepper --
one for film, one for
video, and one for audio.
And we serve to our
research patrons here
through a range of
access initiatives.
This is the 10th anniversary
of the NAVCC.
That's our acronym for National
Audio-Visual Conservation Center.
So we've been at that
for about 10 years.
We are also written
into the legislation
that authorized the National
Film Preservation Board
and the National Recording
Preservation Board.
The NAVCC is part of
that law that --
written in as to help implement
the national plans that the Library
of Congress has published in
the last couple of decades
for recorded sound collections
and for our nation's
moving image heritage.
The collections of the
Library of Congress itself,
the audio-visual collections,
we have some 3.6 million audio
collections, sound recordings,
including many hundreds of thousands
of radio, hours, and items.
We collect commercial, public,
and government-produced materials
from national networks to local
stations, programming of news,
dramatic programming,
music, sports, talk radio.
In fact, talk radio, actually,
embodies one of our
more recent initiatives.
Another law that we have that --
that the Library of Congress has
is called the American Television
and Radio Archive Act.
It was part of the
Copyright Act of 1976.
It mandates that the
Library of Congress establish
and grow an American
television and radio archive.
We've recently expanded the
regulations governing that act
to include a unique
authority to be able
to capture unpublished audio-visual
transmissions from any format,
from any venue, whether satellite,
cable, off-air, off-Internet,
satellite radio, FM radio.
And a number of years ago we began
capturing political talk radio,
talk radio in general with a special
focus on political talk radio.
That's an activity still on-going.
You can see what we've been
capturing over the years
in our Recorded Sound
Research Center website.
So we constantly have radio on our
minds as we continue to acquire
and preserve our audio-visual
collections.
Our newest major activity
you're going to be hearing more
about throughout the
Congress, this conference,
and this afternoon
especially, is our collaboration
with WGBH Educational
Foundation up in Boston.
I guess we're going
into our third year now
of having assumed the
responsibilities
for managing the ongoing
preservation development
of the American Archive of
Public Broadcasting, AAPB,
an initiative established
by the Corporation
for Public Broadcasting
a number of years ago.
And about three years
ago WGBH and the Library
of Congress assumed
responsibility for continuing that.
To date we have ingested into our
Data Center, our Digital Archive
at the Packard Campus, over 71 radio
collections from around the country,
with numerous more in the
pipeline being developed
through grant initiatives
and negotiated agreements
with radio stations.
This broad initiative to
capture publicly-funded media
in the United States is off to a
great success, and I hope that many
of you will be attending this
afternoon's 2 p.m. 50th anniversary
celebration of public
broadcasting in this country.
You're going to see an
all-star cast of dignitaries
in this room later this afternoon.
So you'll be seeing a lot of other
Library of Congress staff here
and tomorrow on various panels that
can fill you in on more details.
I want to conclude just by
giving some thank you's.
I consulted with Josh
Shepperd earlier.
And we do have a number of people
that I would like to thank now,
not only on behalf of the
Library, but also the leadership
of the National Radio
Preservation Taskforce,
including all of the Radio
Preservation Taskforce --
conference directors, project
directors, caucus chairs,
and all of you participants,
the Association
for Recorded Sound
Collections, CLIR,
the International Communication
Association,
National Communication Association,
NPR, the Maryland Institute
for Technology and the Humanities,
the Woodrow Wilson
International Center for Scholars,
the National Council on
Public History, Nemnon,
and the National Recording
Preservation Foundation,
and a number of individuals,
Michelle Helms,
a Conference Director, Sam
Berlofski [assumed spelling],
Stephanie Sapienza,
Trevor Munoz, Ross Johnson,
Pietra Beerstacker [assumed
spelling], Julie Rogers,
Justin Winn, Laura Soto-Barra, Jan
Jones, Mike Casey, Laura Sawyer,
David Park, Paige Hunter,
Trevor Giles,
Randon [assumed spelling]
Burke, Jane Curry,
Shaun Vancoeur [assumed spelling],
Wendy Shay, and a special shoutout
to Christine Ehrick, the
Communications Director
for the Taskforce for the article
in the Washington Post
that appeared yesterday
on this gathering, and radio
preservation in general.
And, of course, the Library
needs to thank Josh Shepperd
for his tireless efforts in
developing the taskforce.
And, of course, I know he wishes
he could be here today as well,
the Founder of the
taskforce, Chris Sterling,
who I'm sure extends his warm
welcomes to all of you as well.
It is an amazing network of a
couple of hundred institutions
that have come together to create
this digital humanities empire
of creators and archivists and
academics who are working together
to focus on radio history
and preservation.
I commend you all,
and I welcome you all.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
You'll introduce yourself,
but I would be remiss
if I didn't just contribute
to introducing Eugene Flanagan who's
a Director of National Programs
in the National and
International Outreach Unit
of the Library of Congress.
Eugene.
[ Applause ]
>> Eugene Flanagan: Good morning.
Actually, if those of you
politely sitting at the back,
if you'd like to grab a
seat, now is a good time.
Won't force you, but there's plenty
of seats here and to the side.
So, thank you, Greg.
As he says, I'm Director
of National Programs.
And it's my great good
fortune that some
of those include the National
Recording Preservation Board
and the National Recording Registry
and their film counterparts.
We had the meeting of
the Film Board yesterday,
and we also had a terrific event
promoting the work of the Board
and the Registry when there was a
conversation between the Librarian
of Congress and the Director,
Christopher Noland, last night.
And I'm hoping we sort of
mirror that to help support
and promote the Recording
Board and Registry.
And the Board meeting's
coming up in December,
and the Register being
announced in March.
And so we were working to see what
we can do along similar lines.
The Library's delighted to
welcome so many institutions
as Greg mentioned, 200, and
individuals that are registered,
300, to participate over
the next couple of days.
Yesterday we saw forums,
panels, and workshops take place
at the Woodrow Wilson, and National
Public Radio, and the University
of Maryland, and here, now,
at the Library of Congress.
Or as the online conference
schedule describes the Library,
the big boxy building
with pillars [laughter].
But it obviously helps because
most of you are here today.
So given the depth and breadth
of participation, it should come
as no surprise that this Radio
Preservation Project is one,
and maybe the largest
digital humanities
in media initiatives in
the discipline today.
And for those of us in cultural
institutions, big boxy buildings
with pillars, are used to
marking progress in decades.
This has come to pass in
relatively short order
that I find very impressive
and commend everybody involved.
In 2013, just to give you a sense
of the pace, under the auspices
of the National Recording
Preservation Board,
the Library released the Library
of Congress National
Recording Preservation Plan,
a comprehensive blueprint
and call to arms
to save America's recorded sound
heritage for future generations.
The report drew from
findings that many recordings
of radio broadcasts
were untraceable,
and numerous transcription
discs of national
and local broadcasts
had been destroyed.
And that little was known
of what still existed,
where it was stored,
and in what condition.
A year later, a key
recommendation was
to implement the Radio
Preservation Task Force.
And this was formed in 2014
to spearhead the effort
to identify challenges and
develop strategies to collect
and preserve American radio
broadcasts and content.
And in 2016 the Taskforce convened
its first National Conference.
Subsequent collaboration
in the years
since has seen several
projects launched,
including the Public Memory
Project, a national project
to preserve the history of public
media, a national project to study
and preserve Cold War communications
history, a beta program
for publicly accessible
bigdata search engine
to locate archival collections,
and aggregating information
about hundreds or archival
collections across the country.
And here we are today in late 2017
at the Second Annual Conference,
ready to fire up the
engines for the year ahead.
So why is this pace, this
sense of urgency important?
It's important because the task
at hand, to quote the title
of an Atlantic article, is Saving
Historic Radio Before It's Too Late
M, a sentiment that was
repeated in, as Greg says,
the Post article yesterday.
We know that radio, like
film, has played a vital role
in the last hundred
years of our history.
From the mid-1920s until the '50s,
radio was the nation's
preeminent source
of entertainment and
news information.
And today, despite the multiplicity
of generations, options, devices,
and platforms, there are still
more than 14,000 radio stations
in the United States, and radio's
still a major source of information
that 93% of us listen
to, even millennials.
I was surprised -- 91%.
Radio is an irreplaceable part
from a sociocultural heritage,
a key part of a social
memory, an ubiquitous,
if perhaps underappreciated,
force in our daily lives.
As you all know much better than I
do, and I appreciate your patience,
radio preservation
presents unique challenges.
The magnitude of the material
produced, it's a femoral nature,
the deregulation and
consolidation of radio stations,
the lack of technology to
preserve early broadcasts,
general institutional
neglect, emerging formats,
and underrepresentation
of diverse [inaudible],
are all contributing factors in
the crisis facing the preservation
of America's radio heritage.
So much was never captured, and
much that was has since disappeared.
Our preservation consciousness
has, of course,
been raised in recent
decades, and many libraries
and archives have acquired
collections
of radio broadcasting recordings.
But there has been
few systematic efforts
to collect commercial radio
broadcasting and to document
and preserve the entire
range of extant broadcasts
in private and public collections.
For the latter, happily, of course,
there is now the American
Archive of Public Broadcasting.
But that still leaves the
vast expanse of commercial
and independent nonprofit
radio that is found
in both the national
and local levels.
This essential work
remains to be done.
And this is why we're here today.
The Taskforce and it's three-day
conference is the first national
attempt by mass media historians
and archivists to assess the history
and record of radio
in the United States.
And for that, and I second Greg
in this, I applaud Chris Sterling
and Josh Shepperd, the Taskforce,
the Conference Committee,
and all of you here today who are
participating over the next couple
of days at the 22-odd sessions.
Thank you very much
and the best of luck.
[ Applause ]
>> Gregory Lukow: I
should probably --
this is where you get
up and disperse.
I should probably give you
a little guidance for that.
There are four sessions that follow.
One of them stays in this
room, so if you're here, stay.
Dining Room A and Dining Room C
are just right on the other side
of this wall, just a few steps away.
And the Mumford, which is where
the other session's being held,
is the big room right behind
where you registered this morning,
where the registration
desk was off the elevators.
So here, to there, and the Mumford,
that's where the four
sessions are meeting.
Good luck.
>> Jenni Monet: And this panel is
entitled "Indigenous First Nations,
Looking at Media Archives
in General,"
coming from our tribal communities.
And since we're getting
a late start,
I just want to also just
mention that we're going
to keep the presentations a little
tight with some room, hopefully,
to leave for some of your questions.
This panel wraps up around 10:45.
My name is Jenni Monet.
I'm a Tribal citizen of
the Pueblo of Laguna,
which is a Tribal Nation
in New Mexico.
I'm an indigenous journalist
and I'm so honored to be here
at this awesome conference where we
get to talk and nerd out on a topic
that I really love which
is indigenous media.
Allow me to introduce the panelists,
and then I'm going to assist them
in working around all of the
files that we have here today.
Starting from my left,
we have Lina Ortega.
She's a Tribal Citizen of the Sac
and Fox Nation out of Oklahoma,
and is speaking to us
from work that she does
with the University of Oklahoma.
To her left is Melissa Begay
who is here representing
Native Public Media .
Loris Taylor was originally
intended to be here.
And Melissa works very
closely with Loris,
and I know that she will
bring in the same remarks
that Loris would have today
about Native Public
Media and Tribal Radio .
To Melissa's left is Michael Pon
with the Smithsonian Museum
as the American Indian.
I'm looking forward to your
remarks as well, Michael.
Thank you for being here.
To Michael's left is
Simon Moya-Smith,
an independent journalist and
soon-to-be author of his first book.
Simon also is going to be
speaking to us from his recent work
of Indian Country Today
which actually shuttered
in early September.
And so, be very interesting
to hear what you have to say
about the archives happening
from Indian Country Today .
And then, finally, last but not
least, we have our discussant,
Amalia Cordova, who comes to us
from the Smithsonian Folk Life.
And she's really going
to bring context
to the greater indigenous worldview
of how these narratives
are shaped and formed.
So, without further ado, I just
want to get started with some
of the conversation here today.
And Melissa, if you would like to
come up here, I can certainly help
with navigating any of
the presentations here.
Please.
[ Applause ]
>> Melissa Begay: Thank you.
Just [inaudible].
>> Jenni Monet: Yeah.
>> Melissa Begay: Okay.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Good morning.
My name is Melissa Begay
as you heard Jenni mention.
I am with Native Public Media .
I'm a member of the
Navajo Nation in Arizona.
And I'm here today filling in for
Loris Taylor as Jenni had mentioned.
She was unable to be with us today.
The presentation today is going
to focus on endangered collections
and the need for expanded academic
study on the cultural history
of radio and, in general,
the history of media
serving Indian Country.
Not much has been compiled
or collected.
But what we do know are bits and
pieces of an incredible story.
It is generally perceived the
Indigenous people's cultures
and traditions are kept alive
through oral traditions,
generation to generations
for thousands of years.
When you think about
it, that's a lot
of information to retain
and to share.
However, not all nations
use oral traditions.
Some nations use birchbark to
capture their writing and there were
and are other examples of written
language used by indigenous people.
Between 1809 and 1821, Sequoyah,
also known as George Guess,
created the Cherokee syllabary.
Sequoyah, a Cherokee
silversmith, simply just wanted
to write his own name like other
silversmith want to sign his work.
He first tried picture
graphs but found
that this would have
required thousands of symbols.
He designed a symbol for each
syllable in the Cherokee language.
The Cherokee symbol, or the
Cherokee syllabary, whether written
in Cherokee language came
into being in the late 1810s.
And in 1828, the Cherokee Nation
adopted the Cherokee syllabary.
And in 1911, the Smithsonian
preserved the language.
The Cherokee Phoenix was the
first Native American newspaper,
the first issue published
in English and Cherokee,
using the Cherokee syllabary,
in February 21, 1980-28.
Elias Boudinot was the first
Editor of The Cherokee Phoenix .
He named The Cherokee
Phoenix as a symbol of renewal
for the mythical bird that rose
to life from the ashes of fire.
The Nation founded the paper to
gather support and help keep members
of the Cherokee Nation
united, informed.
It was also a platform to
discuss political decisions
that would eventually result
in the Trail of Tears.
It was a part of a movement
to help the Cherokee Nation
create self-governing institutions
in the new capital of Echota.
Other tribal nations beside
the Cherokee also started
to print newspapers.
They include the Cherokee,
Chickasaw, Choctaw, and Creek,
and were influenced by tribal
leaders, and gave an official voice
to the elders and leadership.
Most newspapers were tribally owned,
and few owned by individual
tribal members.
In 1935, the second Native
American paper, The Shawnee Sun ,
was published both in
English and Shawnee,
also using the English alphabet.
It was suspended in 1838
and resumed in 1841.
By 1858, there was a
Chickasaw and Choctaw Herald ,
and by the 1840s tribes were
investing in official papers.
Both tribal papers and
native writers were active
through the 1850s.
However, as the political
situation of tribes shifted to that
of assimilation or allotment,
publishing had weakened
and declined.
To this day, tribal officials
or the tribal government usually
control tribal newspapers.
And as you see on this slide, a
little bit history and timeline
of the newspapers starting
from Sequoyah to the 2000s.
It's also important to mention
Myrta Eddleman was the first Native
American woman to own
a mainstream newspaper.
In 1898, Myrta launched the
Twin Territories which focused
on Tribal Indian Territory
in Oklahoma.
Myrta's sister, Ora Eddleman, later
became Reed, served as the Editor
and Chief Writer for
Twin Territories .
Between 1900 and 1940, publishers
and editors supported assimilation,
control most public -- I'm sorry.
I'm going to repeat that.
Between 1900 and 1940,
publishers and editors
who supported assimilation
controlled most publications.
A number of tribal publications
were started during this period.
A few of them are, The
California Indian News , 1935;
The Winnebago Chieftain
, 1905, in Nebraska;
The Claremore State
Herald , 1905, in Oklahoma;
The Rossville Reporter
, 1913, in Kansas.
Now moving on to Native radio.
KYUK was the first
Tribal radio station.
It went on air in 1971,
followed by KDKB
in Pinehill, New Mexico in 1972.
Forty-six years later,
in 2017, that has grown
to approximately 59 tribal radio
stations across Indian Country.
Native radio is a powerful network
of individuals and organizations
that support and encourage
one another.
Radio stations are
often owned and operated
by Native American Indigenous
groups, many on tribal lands
in tribal communities, and
also a few in urban areas.
Radio programs in series
are developed
by Native producers focused
on Native issues and cultures.
Native [inaudible] is
significant to both Native
and non-Native audiences
for a number of reasons.
It gives indigenous
communities a powerful voice
that reinforces a sense of community
through the lens of
their own language.
It can provide news from
the Native point of view,
and health programs focusing on
local issues and local needs.
It can broadcast music and culture
programs that support traditional
and nontraditional Native artists.
In 2013, Peggy Berryhill, a 42-year
veteran radio producer stated,
"We love Native radio."
Announcers sound like us.
We hear the latest music.
We hear the latest news.
He hear our language.
And we hear emergency
information that can save lives.
Native people through the world
had little if any opportunity
to hear their language
over the radio.
Majority of cultures
dominated the airwaves,
and most Nations saw little value
in supporting indigenous
cultures in any form.
It is through tribal radio tribal
members can hear their language
and possibly rescue
it from extinction.
Since radio was an oral medium,
it appeared to be ideally
situated for this purpose.
In 2012, 21 stations broadcasted
in their tribal language.
A year later, that grew to 36
radio stations broadcasting
in their tribal language.
And you see a few examples
on the screen there.
Native radio strengthens
the retention of native
and indigenous languages.
It supports arts and
cultural initiatives.
It airs discussions of current
affairs from perspective
of indigenous people, and continues
to bridge the cultural divide.
Moving from native radio, I want
to now highlight some Native
Americans mainstream media.
Native American journalists --
Tanna Beebe, a member of the Cowlitz
tribes of Washington State --
sorry if I pronounced that wrong --
was one of the first
Native American hired
by a nonnative-owned TV station,
KIRO TV in Seattle
in the early 1970s.
Hattie Kauffman, a Nez Perce tribal
member, started her broadcast career
on college radio at the
University of Minnesota.
In 1987, she worked
for Good Morning,
America as a special correspondent
and substitute news anchor,
then joined CBS This Morning
in 1990, where she also served
as a special correspondent
and substitute anchor.
We have Mary Kim Titla, a member
of the San Carlos Apache Tribe,
who became the first Native
American television journalist
in Arizona in 1987.
She worked for KBOA in Tucson
and KPNX in Phoenix, Arizona.
These pioneers Native
television journalists led the way
for many others such as Andy
Harvey, Charlie Etsitty, and others.
And then we have our
television station, FNX,
First Nation Experience,
airing in 2011,
the Cheyenne Arapaho television
station in 2012, in Oklahoma.
And then just recently, in 2014, the
Gila River Broadcasting Corporation,
the Gila Rivera Indian
Community in Arizona.
We also have tribal web-based media.
Indian Country Today Media
Network launched in 2001,
and is a news Aggregator.
RezKast, a Native video and
music-sharing site, created in 2005
by the Coeur d'Alene
Tribal IT Department.
According to RezKast
website, this is a place
where they can create
their own tribal shows,
report on their own
tribal programming
and their own native content.
It is their hope and their intent
that tribal people will use
technology's greatest strengths
to preserve the greatest truths.
And then we have indiancountrytv.com
which streams news
from Indian Country
and Indian Country TV.
And then the Chickasaw TV.
Chickasaw Nation TV is a
high-definition online video network
owned by the Chickasaw Nation,
focusing on tribal history,
traditions, arts, cultural,
and services.
The website consists of nine
channels -- government, commerce,
news, history and culture,
arts and humanities.
The website currently
contains hundreds
of short videos covering
Chickasaw government programs
and services, events and issues.
This map displays Native
America media today.
In yellow are the radio
stations across Indian Country.
Purple are podcasts.
Red are weekly podcasts.
Blue represents newspapers
across Indian Country.
And then green represents blogs
by Native Americans
across Indian Country.
We know that new technology
are changing native radio
and media in radical ways.
Broadband Internet provides
opportunity for online streaming,
satellite radio, and
distribution of programs.
Also, low-cost digital technology
such as tablets, cell phones,
and other devices have broadened
access to tribal media as well.
So good things are happening.
The good things are going
on in Indian Country.
There is a small collection
of native media
and Native Public Media
encourages academia to be more open
to collecting and archiving
tribal media.
Again, thank you so much
for inviting Native
Public Media here today.
Again, my name is Melissa Begay.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jenni Monet: Thank you, Melissa.
And what an appropriate introduction
to this panel discussion, I think.
I really appreciate that overview.
Lina, would you like to go next?
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Sure.
>> Jenni Monet: Okay.
That would be great.
I was going to put this up here.
And would you feel
comfortable being at the podium?
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Yes.
>> Jenni Monet: Okay.
Great. Now, again, let me
know if I can assist you
with any navigation
in getting your files.
Let me just line this up here.
Okay. And now yours is not this one.
This is yours.
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Okay.
>> Jenni Monet: And I believe we
downloaded it as well, correct?
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Yes.
>> Jenni Monet: Okay.
Here it is.
There's that.
Now, to access your audio
files, Escape -- sorry.
And if you just move the cursor
down, I'm going to pull up iTunes.
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Okay.
>> Jenni Monet: Okay?
Does that sound okay?
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Yeah.
>> Jenni Monet: Great.
I'm going to bring that
down and bring your --
There you are.
Okay. Thank you for that transition.
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Okay.
All right.
Thank you.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
I'm really thrilled to be here
today to talk about the Indians
for Indians Hour Radio Program .
It started on April 1 in
1941, and it was broadcast
from the WNAD AM Station
right on the campus
of the University of Oklahoma.
And from the very beginning
it was a very popular show.
It was the creation of Don Whistler,
who was a Sac and Fox Indian,
and he was also Chief of
the Tribe at that time.
He had been educated
in Sac and Fox Country.
He grew up in Sac and Fox Country.
And then as a young man he
attended the University of Oklahoma.
And then he also went to the
University of Pennsylvania
and worked in the museum
as a curator and also
as a lecturer and performer.
And so these are a couple
of photographs of him
from when he was a young man.
And on the right, you see
him wearing a headdress
which is not what Sac
and Fox warriors
or chiefs traditionally wear.
But he would wear it
during his performances.
And he would -- whenever he
was lecturing to Boy Scouts
and other groups in Pennsylvania,
he performed dances and songs
from other tribes, not
just the Sac and Fox.
This photograph is
from later in life.
And he's talking to one of
the anthropologists on campus
at our Natural History Museum.
And I think this photograph
is from about the same time
that he would have started the
Indians for Indians Hour .
And he was also its host
for its first 10 years,
from 1941 through 1951.
And he invited Native Americans
from all over the state.
He had a wide network evidently
-- in Central Oklahoma,
in Western Oklahoma, and some
getting into the eastern part
of the state, but maybe not so
much, because there are a few tribes
that really aren't well
represented in the radio show.
It was broadcast on
Tuesday afternoons
for half an hour at l o'clock.
But it was called Indians
for Indians Hour popularly.
So that's just the weekly schedule.
This is a program schedule
from 1948.
This one is also from 1948,
and it talks about the
popularity of the show.
It says, "More and more
Indians are finding Indians
for Indians to be one
of their favorite series.
The programs include real
Indian music, songs, and dances,
presented by representatives of
tribes from all over the state.
Don Whistler arranges for the
appearance of these groups and is
in complete charge of the series."
And he was.
He was very explicit that
this program was being put
on by Indian people, and
it was for Indian people,
and he never waivered from that.
However, once he did invite someone,
sometimes -- usually it was groups,
sometimes individuals, he
let them take it from there.
He would introduce them.
He could make some comments.
And then he would let them
do whatever they wanted to,
sing whatever they wanted to.
There was also a lot of --
the program mostly was
performances and music.
And I'll get into details
in that a little bit later.
But also it was spoken, too.
There were speeches,
there were prayers.
And so he let, once
people were there,
he let them do what they wanted.
The only thing is he
didn't want anyone getting
into political discussions.
Indian Country politics
can get kind of --
always has, probably always will,
can get kind of heated sometimes.
That was not the format of the show.
The Western History
Collections at OU is one
of the special collections
in the Library.
And we also house the
University Archives.
So that's where some of this
material is coming from.
We're fortunate to
have Whistler's logbook
that he created for
planning his show.
And this is a couple
of pages from it.
And the arrangement of the
book is kind of interesting.
He would put paper in this
binder and then, as time went on,
he would add to the top of it.
And so this first page
from the first programs
in 1941 is actually at
the end of the book.
So we have his first
show, April 1st.
And then the second
show on April 8th.
You probably can't see it, but it
says, "Yellow Fish [inaudible]."
And this is one -- I actually
don't know if Yellow Fish sang
on this program, but he did talk.
This is one of the recordings
that -- it no longer exists.
Not every program was recorded,
or the recordings were saved,
and then I think there were
some that were recorded,
and they've been lost over time.
So, anyway, Yellow
Fish had participated
in the Battle of Adobe Walls.
So this is 1941 and I believe
he's in his 70s at this time.
And that battle was, I
believe, in 1874 in Texas.
And it was kind of the last
stand, if you want to put it
that way, for the Comanche.
And so he's -- he was there.
He was a teenager when
this was going on.
And so that's what he's talking
about during this episode.
So it's tragic that that
recording doesn't exist.
The content of the show, as
I said, it mostly was music.
But it was a variety of music.
It was powwow music, so
it included war dances,
what we now refer to
as intertribal songs.
It had round dances, war
mother songs, 49 songs.
It also had religious
music of different kinds.
Some of it would be Christians
singing Christian hymns.
But it was different denominations
from churches from
all over the state.
And so some of these hymns would
be from more the Eastern Tribes,
like the Creek or the Seminoles.
And then you would also have more
of the Western Tribes
in Oklahoma represented.
Rainy Mountain Church in
Kiowa Country is one example.
And so these groups would be
-- they would come and perform.
There would also be
stomp dance music.
And then also ceremonial
music, you know,
traditional tribal ceremonial music,
which is a little surprising to me.
Some of the songs, for
example, are sun dance songs
from the Cheyenne or
the Arapaho Tribes.
And it astonishes me that
they actually performed
that on live radio.
And we still have these recordings.
So that's something that I'd really
like to talk to the tribe about,
you know, what do you
think of this now?
As far as some of the
spoken content goes,
some of it is -- talks
about history.
There's a lot of it
in a tribal language,
and so we don't necessarily
know what they're saying.
And there's a lot of
tributes to veterans.
And school groups would
often come and perform, too.
And so sometimes we have students
talking or they're singing.
It's like Whistler gave them an
opportunity for both the elders
to perform and to participate
in the show,
and then also for the young
people to do that as well,
and kind of show their elders
that they're carrying things on.
So I'd like to go ahead and
play a few clips for you.
I'm not certain this is going to
work correctly, but let me see.
Yeah, I did Escape.
>> Jenni Monet: Just
get it there faster.
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Okay.
>> Jenni Monet: Here's the iTunes.
>> Lina Ortega Melissa
Begay: Okay, thank you.
>> Jenni Monet: Okay?
You're welcome.
And then just click on [inaudible].
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Okay.
This first one I'm going to
play is Whistler himself.
And so I'd like for
you to hear his voice.
And he normally didn't
venture into politics,
but he does have some
commentary here.
We're not going to hear it all
just because of the length,
but he's talking about the
NCAI, urging Indian people
to write their congressmen
about a proposed bill that was
in the House at that time.
>> Jenni Monet: Wait --
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Okay.
>> Indians for Indians
with Don Whistler.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> This is the 353rd
program of the Indian
for Indians Hour ,
[inaudible] speaking.
Before we start on this
program which is going
to be a continuous
affair [inaudible],
make one little announcement here.
It seems that someone is always
introducing bills in Congress asking
for things for Indians
without ever taking the trouble
to ask the Indians whether
they want it or not.
And then some [inaudible] American
Indians just written me a letter
saying that there is now in
the print a bill, HR 4725.
That's HR 4725, that confers
jurisdiction on the several states
over offenses committed by
or against Indians on
Indian Reservations.
The National Congress of American
Indians think that they could --
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Okay.
I'm sorry to cut it off, but it
goes on for a little bit longer.
So he always started his
show off by saying --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And he's saying hello,
friends [foreign words].
That was his clan name.
It is I speaking.
And so that's what
that translates to.
Anther one -- this next clip
is one of the early broadcasts.
It's from 1943 and the speaker
is Tsatoke who is Kiowa.
At this time in 1942
he's 96 years old.
And he lives to be 107 years old.
His name is Hunting Horse in Kiowa.
And you can only imagine
what he must have seen
in his long lifetime during
a period of enormous change.
So here's a clip of
him speaking in Kiowa.
Yeah.
[ Singing in Foreign Language ]
He's singing several types of
songs, and he doesn't start speaking
until a little bit later.
I apologize, but the way that I made
the clips doesn't really transfer
onto another person's computer.
I can fast-forward
it, but, of course,
it's going to cause some
squealing in the meantime.
Do you think I should try
that or just leave it?
>> Jenni Monet: Actually,
if you move the cursor.
Do you know that way
where the timecode is?
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Yes.
It's about 13.
>> Jenni Monet: There's 12:42, 13.
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Okay.
>> Jenni Monet: Let's try that.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
I'm sorry.
I probably cut him off in
the middle of his sentence,
but as you can hear, he
has a very strong voice.
He's speaking in a
very animated way.
And he speaks for several minutes.
Some of these speeches are
combinations of just talking
about a certain topic, and
sometimes they'll go into a prayer.
So I think this clip is -- I would
like to know what he's saying.
Really, it's a simple
matter of finding out.
The Kiowa language
is taught on campus,
and so we have Kiowa instructors.
The campus's tribal
liaison is Kiowa,
and so he speaks the language.
And so the Library -- I'll talk
about this a little bit more,
but one of our things that we
need to do is to draw in some
of our colleagues from across campus
to achieve better descriptions
of these episodes, so.
The next one --
I'll just do one more.
And, again, I'm going to
have to advance it some.
I think I see how to do it now.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> My name is Tom.
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Okay.
I'm going to pause
it just for a moment.
Thank you for bearing with me.
As I said, school groups
sometimes participated.
The Pawnee Indian School was a
frequent group that would come
and visit and perform on the show.
Sometimes they would sing.
In this particular clip,
the students are very
earnestly reading an essay
that they had written for school,
where the general team has --
or general theme has to do with
advancement under education.
So this particular boy is
named Thomas Rough Face.
And I'll start it.
>> My name is Thomas Rough Face.
I am 12 years old and
in the sixth grade
at Pawnee Indian School,
Pawnee, Oklahoma.
I am a member of the Ponca Tribe.
Indians today live in a world
where old conditions are
changing, rapidly changing.
Yeah, school conditions are
changing to new, modern ways.
Indians do not live
in tents and teepees
out by themselves as
they used to do.
But they are living in
modern homes and must live
and work under modern conditions.
Indians today, even our
stores, condition [inaudible]
on very large and good farms.
They earn their own money.
Today you see Indians driving
around in very good cars,
going into colleges,
and working in offices.
Indians get good jobs
and earn good money,
but do we know how to spend it?
>> Lina Ortega Melissa
Begay: So he goes on to talk
about how Indian people are
learning to use banks and also
in agriculture, learning
about erosion and so forth.
This clip is from 1948, you know,
some years after the Great
Depression and the dust storms
in that part of the country.
So, anyway, I just
wanted you to hear some
of the participants' own voices,
and get an idea the variety
that's in this radio program.
I'm going to go back
to the slideshow now.
How do I -- hit play?
Do I hit play?
>> Jenni Monet: Yes, right there.
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Okay.
>> Jenni Monet: Thank you.
>> Lina Ortega Melissa
Begay: All right.
Thank you.
The one clip that I didn't
play is Solomon Kent.
It's also from 1948.
And he speaks about
honoring veterans,
and this is something that's very
important to Native Americans.
It's a frequent topic in the show.
And I find his pattern of
speech very interesting
because it's repetitive.
It takes him like four
minutes to say
that around Memorial Day people
are remembering their loved ones
who have passed on, especially
soldiers who have served
and given their life for their
country and for their families.
And it's very moving.
I grew up hearing people
speak like this.
I still do.
But, you know, working where
I do and in daily life,
you don't hear people speak
like that quite so much.
And so it's just interesting to
hear that type of pattern of speech.
This is just a photograph
that was taken of the show.
I'm assuming that it
happens around Christmas
because I think the design that's on
the lady's book is a Christmas tree.
Unfortunately, in our files,
this couple is not identified,
and we don't have the date
of when the photo was taken.
The show was extremely popular.
It was from the beginning.
And it continued to be popular.
This article is from the
student newspaper in 1953.
And then, unfortunately,
Whistler passed away in 1951.
And when he died, he was
still host of the show
and he was still Chief of the tribe.
And so I'm assuming that
he passed away suddenly.
But the show continued
even after his death.
It was sponsored by the Sequoyah
Club, which is the Indian Club
on campus, and its staff
sponsor was Boyce Timmons.
And they carried on
through the 1950s
and the '60s and into
the early '70s.
The show had become kind of an
institution to Indian people
across the state, I think.
There are files of all these
requests that people had written
in for announcements that
they wanted on the show.
And sometimes people
would write in requesting
to be placed on the schedule.
They did this regularly.
And so these are just
a few examples.
One of these is the Sequoyah Indian
Club announcing their homecoming
dance, the Native American Church,
the actual state organization,
announcing their annual meeting.
The signal evidently reached into
Kansas because we have a letter
from the Wichita Intertribal
Club announcing a dance.
And then there's also other
correspondence that students
from Haskell would write in.
And also there were student
groups that would come
from Wichita to perform on the show.
And then we have a whole lot
of these handwritten postcards
where someone is just
announcing a birthday celebration.
They're going to play a hand game to
celebrate this young man's birthday.
And this is more of the same.
We even have an official --
we have a government memo
wanting the open house
for a new Indian Health
Service Unit to be announced.
The announcing a Veterans
Day celebration.
And so Hominy, this
would be the Osage Tribe.
And the Kiowa Gourd Clan
announcing one of their events.
And they have their own beautiful,
very elegant-looking stationery.
So it was just fascinating to
me to see the variety of forms
that people used to
request announcements.
We have telegrams, too.
These particular requests all date
from the early '60s -- 1960 and '61.
So the show's still very vital.
This next one -- this is kind
of changing gears a little bit.
It was from that same file, so I
assume it's from the early '60s.
And it says, "It is a
matter of policy for WNAD
to erase all tapes unless
specifically requested."
And so I think this explains why
we don't have recordings fro all
the episodes.
OU has the most complete set.
It's a very unique holding.
The Library of Congress has a
couple of reel-to-reel tapes
that we do not have from 1943.
And they also have a copy
of reel-to-reels of the 1941
through 1951 shows that they made,
because OU had sent the original
acetate disk here to be copied,
and then they sent back
archival-quality copies
on reel-to-reel.
Unfortunately, it is not known
what happened to the acetate disk.
Our records say that they were
retained by LOC for preservation.
And their records say that
they're returned to OU.
And so I'm not blaming anyone.
This has happened -- this has
been the case for a long time.
But it's just a mystery what
happened to those original disks.
And then as time went on,
the originals are recorded
on reel-to-reels.
But we don't have all of them.
You know, if you think about
it being a weekly show,
there should be, you
know, many reels.
But for the decade of the
'50s we only have about 30.
It's the same situation
for the 1960s.
And then we only have seven
or eight from the early 1970s.
And those tend to just be
the annual anniversary shows.
But we also have about 30
that are labelled "unknown."
And so, clearly, we need
to find out when they're
from and what the content is.
In the process of preparing
a grant proposal
to have the reels digitized, I took
some photographs to send to some
of the vendors, because I'm wanting
to outsource the digitization
of this collection.
I do not -- neither I nor my staff
have the expertise to do this.
And so these are just a
couple of the photographs
that I had to send to them.
And so their remarks were,
"The tape is coming unwound."
"It's not fixed."
"This is a preservation concern."
On the right you can see the boxes.
They're still in their
original boxes.
We haven't rehoused them.
We provide access to the
shows through cassette tapes.
Copies were made to cassettes
in the late 1980s I believe.
And that is what we use when
people come into our Reading Room
and request to listen to them.
And they also -- that's what we use
to digitize things just
on a one-off basis.
This last slide just shows our
description, how much it can vary.
And this is one of
the access problems
that we experience
with this program.
On the left we have one
that's very detailed.
It lists all the performers.
On the right it says,
"Singers, undated.
Unidentified music and
dances on tape 128."
So it is true that we can
listen to the cassette tapes
and get all this information.
But it needs to be
done systematically.
And also, I have a concern that
the cassette tapes are close
to 30 years old, and
they going to break.
Also I have noticed the cassette
tapes are not always a faithful
reproduction of the reels.
There's like one episode
will just be broken, right?
It will stop suddenly and
another one will start.
So it's interrupted, so.
If you're interested in seeing the
inventory list, please contact me.
I'd be happy to hear from you.
And moving forward, like I said,
I'm trying to apply to CLIR,
to the Council on Library
and Information Resources,
to their Recordings at Risk Grant
Program, to have it digitized.
And also to get better descriptions.
And we're also going to
feature the show in an exhibit
in the Main Library next year,
and we're hoping that as part
of that we'll be able to draw on
more members of the campus community
and the state community to get
better descriptions for the show,
and do a better job of preserving,
you know, this very unique treasure.
So, thank you so much
for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Jenni Monet: Thank you, Lina,
for bring up some very interesting
dialog to this conversation.
Michael, would you like to go next?
>> Michael Pahn: Sure.
>> Jenni Monet: Great.
You don't have to step up here.
Whatever you'd like.
>> Michael Pahn: Oh, well, in that
case, I'll just stay right here.
>> Jenni Monet: Okay.
>> Michael Pahn: I'm Michael Pahn.
I'm the Head Archivist
at the National Museum
of the American Indian,
and I was very gratified
when I was asked to
be on this panel.
Is this --
>> Simon Moya-Smith:
You've got to [inaudible].
>> Michael Pahn: Sorry.
I was gratified to be asked to be
on this panel, but I also was kind
of confronted with the reality,
which is that NMAI doesn't have
a lot of radio in our archive,
which is kind of a
blind spot for us.
So I'm going to tell you a little
bit about the National Museum
of the American Indian Archive
and some radio programming
that we have done as a museum, and
then talk about why I think we need
to turn our attention towards
collecting radio programming.
So the National Museum of the
American Indian became part
of the Smithsonian in 1990,
but the actual origins
of the institution date
back far longer than that.
George Gustav Heye,
who founded the museum,
began collecting Native American
material culture in the late 1890s,
and almost from the
beginning conceived
of his collection as a museum.
And then did actually
open a museum in 1916.
And his concept, as was sort of
the fashion of the day, I guess,
was that Native Americans
were a dying people.
They were going to be assimilated
into mainstream culture.
All evidence of their
heritage would be obliterated,
and it was up to wealthy
white people like him
to collect the evidence
of their heritage
and make it available
to other white scholars.
And for decades, that's
how they proceeded.
I think that one of the really
fascinating and maybe untold,
or undertold parts of the
story of the National Museum
of the American Indian
is that transformation
from being an institution
largely for white people
by white people intended
for, you know,
sort of a colonialist audience, to
being an institution run largely
by Native People, who conceives of
our audience and our constituency
as being the Native People
of the Western Hemisphere,
that we are an institution
dedicated to documenting the lives
of the Native People of the Western
Hemisphere and largely in support
of revitalizing those cultures,
of making cultural heritage
available to community members.
So we very much think of
ourselves as the stewards
of the cultural heritage
of the Western Hemisphere.
When George Gustav Heye began
the museum, and for many,
many years after that, they
were really focused on this kind
of unrealistic idea that there was
sort of a perfect moment in the past
that truly represented what Native
People's lives were really like,
and that they were going to
collect and document that stuff.
And so, for a long time, archival
materials were not really part
of the picture because they were
looking for archeological materials
or some sort of ethnographic
materials that met a kind
of standard that they
as curators set.
So our collections, our archival
collections, are not nearly
as robust or as historical as
our material culture collections.
And we also have the benefit of
being part of the Smithsonian
which has the National
Anthropological Archive
which dates back to, you know, their
collections date back to the 1860s.
So we don't try to collect
anthropological records.
So in terms of the archives in
the Museum of the American Indian,
we've kind of been
triangulating towards a niche.
And that niche is that we
document the contemporary lives
of the Native People of
the Western Hemisphere,
and seek to demonstrate the
connections that people make,
and the context that they're
contemporary lives have
with their traditions.
And so we do this by collecting
the personal papers of artists
and writers and leaders
and activists,
and the organizational records
of Native American Civil
Rights Organizations
such as the National Congress
of the American Indian.
We have about 50 years
worth of their papers.
So what I'm kind of
driving at is that we seek
to contextualize people's
contemporary lives
and how the traditions that
they have been raised in
and the continuity of
Native culture informs those
contemporary experiences.
Well, radio is a really
great medium for that.
It's interesting that I
learned about the Indians
for Indians Hour because
one of our staff people,
a man named Ed Shoopman
[assumed spelling],
who runs our National
Education Initiative,
used to work at the Library
of Congress in the 1970s,
and I believe that he's the person
who might have been responsible
for having the Library of Congress
preserve those acetate recordings,
because he told me about going to
Oklahoma and hearing the Indians
for Indians Hour , and -- I mean,
what a perfect example of how --
if people throughout the world,
and the Western Hemisphere's
no different,
they've always used the technology
and the mediums at their disposal.
This gets to what you
were talking about,
about newspapers and broadcasting.
So we do have collections
of media producers.
We have, for instance, the records
of a really fabulous Native American
filmmaker and documentarian,
Phil Lucas, who made really
terrific programs in the late 1970s.
He made a series of television
programs about the portrayal
of Indians in Hollywood
and on television, and if,
when you watch this, images on
Indians -- when you watch it today,
it is exactly as current
and informative
as it was when it was made.
I mean, which is kind of a sad
statement about the progress
that mainstream media has made
in representing Native People.
But he did a really great job
of making a fantastic series
of documentaries about that.
The Museum of the American Indian
has made, as far as I am aware of,
only one foray into radio
production ourselves.
And it was in the late 1990s.
I believe they were
published in 2001.
It's a series called Living
Voices , and it was produced
by two long-time staff
people, Elizabeth Weatherford,
who just recently retired, but
for over 30 years ran our Film
and Video Public Program., and
Keevin Lewis, who also just retired.
But Keevin ran a really great
program, bring Native artists
into work with collections which
is just a really special thing
about NMAI.
It's one of the more gratifying
things about working there.
So Living Voices was 40
Dort profiles of Native people
and leaders, contemporary leaders.
It's kind of assembled
from more than,
I think, 100 separate interviews.
And in addition to the 40
episodes that are in English,
20 of them were also in Spanish,
because as I mentioned
several times,
we are a hemispheric organization.
We represent and collect --
people, Native people of the
entire Western Hemisphere,
including Hawaii.
We don't actually collect Hawaiian
materials, but we do programming
about Hawaiian, Native
Hawaiian people.
So that program, Living Voices
, is freely available online.
You can listen to it.
You can buy CDs or
DV -- no, not DVDs.
Just CDs of it.
But the original recordings
and the production
materials are also available.
I mean, obviously, these
are in-depth interviews
that were edited down.
That's sort of the nature
of media production.
So we are aware, as an institution,
of the value of broadcasting,
of the value of radio.
It isn't an area that
we have collected
with a great deal of focus.
But I ask all of you,
as participants
in the Radio Preservation
Taskforce and people who think
about this all the time, to please
think of the National Museum
of the American Indian as a
repository for radio programming.
We are fortunate to
have a really fabulous,
incredible collections facility, the
Cultural Resources Center located
in Suitland, Maryland,
about seven miles from here.
That's where the archive is based.
And we have the infrastructure
of the Smithsonian to help us
with our preservation concerns.
So please think and
help me learn more
about indigenous radio programming
and collecting opportunities.
So, I'm here, and if you'd like to
contact me, I have business card,
and would love to hear from
you and speak with you,
and learn about the
potential collaborations
or collections that
may be out there.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jenni Monet: Thank you, Michael.
Simon, would you like to
make some remarks next?
>> Simon Moya-Smith: [Inaudible].
Sorry, I'm usually on my
third cappuccino by now,
so I only had a small black
coffee, so this is painful.
Oh.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
My name is Simon Moya-Smith.
I'm a reporter, I think.
And I'm not objective.
I give my opinion.
I bring the Native lens, you know.
I mean, that's the thing, is I --
somebody once asked me if I was a,
you know, so you cover
Indian Country.
You just cover Native news.
Like, no. I'm a Native reporter and
I bring the Native lens to news.
And, you know -- by the way, happy
Native American Heritage Month.
It is. This is Native
American Heritage Month.
This is the time where we get to
recognize us and our resilience,
that we survived the
Founding Fathers.
We survived westward expansion.
We survived boarding
schools, massacres,
murders, rapes, all of it.
And this is the time where
we get to celebrate the fact
that we survived all of these people
who have statues to themselves all
over this district of
Christopher Columbus.
And people forget that.
People don't -- I mean, we just go
and just say Washington,
D.C. No, it's Columbia.
This is the District of
Christopher Columbus.
And what's the sports mascot?
I mean, think of the message that
we're sending to people every day,
so know that we're in the
District of Christopher Columbus,
and the sports mascot is a reference
to a time where we were bountied.
And at the same time, we're the
most likely to be killed by cops.
And people don't know that.
We're here talking
about media, right?
And the fact that we're
so still cancelled
out of the American
conversation across the board.
I've gotten phone calls
from my fellow African
American colleagues saying, hey,
I'm about to go on Fox Business .
Can you tell me a little
bit about natives?
I'm about to talk with them.
It's like, then why
are you going on?
Nobody -- I wouldn't do that.
I wouldn't do that.
I wouldn't call my African
American colleague and say, hey,
I'm going to go and talk
about Black Lives Matter.
No, it would be like I would sit
down and you should be doing this.
But that's the problem is that
we are the uncomfortable reminder
of what this country has done, is
doing, and will continue to do,
unless we're included
in these discussions.
So one that I -- I
just wanted attention.
One thing I'd like to start
doing though is I like to --
we have to recognize that all
of us are sitting here right now
still on indigenous territory.
And they are not here,
predominantly not
because they decided
to leave voluntarily.
That just because they
weren't white Christian,
they were aggressively
and forcibly removed.
So let's recognize that we are
all right now, because I'm Oglala.
My people are in the Pine Ridge Res
in South Dakota in the Black Hills.
Even I'm a beneficiary of aggressive
Native removal in this territory.
So we need to recognize our
privilege in that sense.
And we hear that all
the time, you know.
It's like, oh, my family's had
this home for six generations.
Well, it's still Indian
land, you know.
And we like to talk about, oh,
my people are like, you know --
I used to hang a lot with
a lot of veterans in Denver
because my grandpa was a veteran.
So I'd go to these
places and they'd say, oh,
we've always fought
for this country.
No, you haven't always
fought for this country.
Because this hasn't
always been an America.
There are restaurants in Italy,
still pumping out biscotti,
that are older than this nation.
And we missed that in the language.
And that's, I guess, my part in this
is that the Native voice and lens
and language, that's
what we're talking about.
The preservation of some of
our languages that are on --
that like some elders will
not speak because of trauma.
My Master's thesis
included an Oglala woman
who would not speak the language
because she was so traumatized,
because she went through boarding
schools that gave her a sick feeling
in her stomach to even
speak her language.
It was so traumatic.
And so I didn't plan
on being a journalist.
I just thought how white people
use language was to fickle,
and it was entertaining to me
that they could say
something and not mean that.
And I'm like, okay, I have
to figure these people out.
And that's when I -- and I
knew that as a kid because I --
well, that's not what I meant.
This is what I said, but
that's not what I meant.
And that was so interesting
to me that it was so fickle,
it was so thin, and
it melts in water.
And that was that -- that became --
I, again, didn't plan
on being a reporter.
I actually was a speech writer
for a state senator trying
to repeal Columbus Day in Colorado
where the holiday was founded
by Irish, not Italians.
Remember that.
And I was offered a position
with The Rocky Mountain News .
And then I realized how much the
Native language and lens pushes back
against the American narrative
and makes people uncomfortable.
And yet we're the ones
that are referenced
as being politically correct.
We're not politically correct.
If you want to read
anything politically correct,
get an American History textbook.
And, sorry.
I'm under strict rules not to cuss,
and sometimes when
you get get fired up.
I don't know many people
who get fired up
and say what the heck [laughter].
So, you know, I got in trouble
for something, actually, you know.
That's how I got into journalism
was I was pulled into an office
at the Colorado State Capitol, and
they said, you wrote this thing
about Columbus Day, and you can't do
that, and you need to take it down.
And if you want a future in politics
here, you got to take that down.
I'm like, [hand-clap],
I'm not an editor.
I filed you.
You got to talk to my editor.
But I realized how that
shook the foundation
of what people think
they know, right?
And listen to the language that
we've agreed on certain things.
You know, for example, we
know that the R word --
I'm not going to say it,
the name of the team here --
is a racial slur that
means proof of Indian kill.
But yet you can go on CNN,
anywhere, NPR, across the board,
and people will say some
people believe it's a slur.
Really? The fact that -- how we -
it's like the idea of it is defined
as such, yet we make
this argument why?
You have to put this
qualifier in there why.
And it's the same thing
when it comes to photos.
If you just on on any website
and it's an Indigenous person
in regalia, those still say costume.
We just saw the tape of a young man
in the '40s trying to teach people
who he was then, and we're still
having that same conversation today.
Why aren't you listening?
Why is it so hard when
the Native voice comes?
Why does it make people shudder?
Because it calls into
question privilege.
The idea that the Indigenous People
did survive everything that --
it's Thanksgiving, right?
People don't want to talk about
the idea that we saved them.
That they were cannibals.
They literally weren't
digging and planting crops.
They were digging and
looking for gold.
So when it came time to
eat, you know what they did.
And this is factually true.
They dug up Indian
graves and ate the flesh.
That's Thanksgiving.
We took care of them while
they were stealing from us.
And after a plague fell through in
the area, there's this whole idea
that the Pilgrims showed up
and that they tilled the --
they didn't till anything.
The came and the land
was already ready to go.
But a plague came through because
of the Spanish and the Dutch.
This is the story, our lens.
Again, our voice.
It's very uncomfortable for
people to take all of this
in because it does call
into question everything
you think you know.
I mean -- and I made some notes
here, but I just really want
to emphasize that now we are
taking media and using it
to provide you the truth,
because it has been used before
against us, propaganda.
Everybody knows Wizard
of Oz , right?
Frank L. Baum.
Do you know what he used to write?
He used to write columns
about how we need
to kill Native Americans,
all of them.
We've wronged them.
There was a Dorothy and, you
know, it was okay, but --
we're going to kill Indians.
That's literally what he did.
He was writing this beautiful little
story that everybody likes to show
to their kids, while
this guy was calling
for the genocide of
Native Americans.
Media was used against
us to demonize us
and strike fear in people.
Now we get to use it to
provide you the truth,
that we aren't merciless
Indian savages as it's written
in the Declaration of Independence.
So we have this opportunity
to even close the gap
that they tried with reservations.
Out of sight, out of mind.
But now there's that
geographic distance isn't there
when you have -- Jesus --
when you have this, right?
I mean, now you have the
Native voice in your pocket,
whether that's written, whether
that's photography, just right away.
So I think one of the problems
that we're still facing is
just getting the Native voice
like welcomed.
I'm sorry to say that.
Just welcomed.
Like the Native lens about these.
You guys can probably go to a
website right now and read something
about like a diversity list.
And we're not included.
We're still in the other category.
We haven't even moved out
of the other category yet.
You can go in a room and people --
like I was at NBC News and they
were celebrating their diversity.
And they went down the
whole diversity list
and didn't mention Natives.
I was just at Columbia, Columbia
Journalism, where I got my master's.
There's not one Native.
I mean these are real problems,
and it sucks that we have
to take it upon ourselves to launch
our own websites, our own podcasts,
to talk about race
and police brutality
and sexual assault, all of that.
Why aren't we included?
That's the question.
Why are Native Americans
still cancelled
out of the American conversation?
What does that serve?
It doesn't serve anything
for any of us.
If anything, it affects
the situation.
So, I can go on like
this, and I won't.
But I will take questions later.
I think the last thing I did want
to say was that my focus of my work,
again, is to provide also a
platform for other Natives.
So when I was at, you know -- well,
Indian Country Today is on hiatus,
and that sucks because
that was a huge platform.
And so you imagine all the stories
that are not being told right now,
and all the shit, sorry, all
the stuff that's happened
in the past month-and-a-half,
and all of those stories
that aren't being told in
our -- about our communities.
And I've tried to provide that
platform to people any time I could,
whether it was at Standing
Rock or, you know,
if it's Oak Flat, et cetera.
Now my question is, you know,
where are you getting it?
Where do you guys -- where are
you guys getting your Native news?
Can you go to the New York Times ?
Can you -- where are you getting it?
And think about that.
Anyway. I'm done.
I'm done.
[ Applause ]
>> Jenni Monet: For
someone with that --
for someone with one cup of
coffee, that's pretty fired up.
>> Simon Moya-Smith:
Oh, yeah [laughter].
>> Jenni Monet: And also, I think it
just really reemphasizes why we're
here and talking about this,
the importance of these stories
that have their roots
so far back and
yet how much work there
is yet to do.
Amalia, could you yet come here.
Let me just log back in really fast.
And I have your presentation
ready to go.
>> Simon Moya-Smith: Sorry.
>> Jenni Monet: I'm just
keeping an eye on the time.
It's 10:31.
>>
>> Amalia Cordova: Yes.
Maybe 10 minutes.
>> Jenni Monet: Yeah?
Thank you.
>> Amalia Cordova: How
do I make this doable?
>> Jenni Monet: You
just start working.
>> Amalia Cordova: Okay.
Yeah. Okay, there we go.
>> Jenni Monet: Yeah.
All right.
>> Amalia Cordova: Thank you.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
I'm Amalia.
I'm greeting you in [foreign words],
which is the Mapuche language
from the [foreign words] territory
which is currently known as Chile
in Argentina, which
is where I was born.
And I'm a language learner still.
And I want to also acknowledge
the traditional territory there,
Piscataway Nation, in which
we are gathered here today.
And I think Simon's
presentation just, you know,
opens up some of the struggles
that are happening across the rest
of the hemisphere in terms
of the right to communication
which is very tied to
the right to exist.
I've been working with Native
media through video mostly.
But there's a predecessor
of video in Latin America
in particular, which
is Native radio.
In many places in Latin America the
Native radio initiative are illegal
because of the concessions
of the air space.
So a lot of the radio
is pirate radio
or radio is working
on borrowed space.
And radio is also a space
that's really important
because it's more affordable
than video in making a film.
And it's also -- it can be deployed
at any time once something happens.
And something did happen
recently on October 8, 2017.
Radio Producer, Efigenia
Vasquez, was shot and killed
at a [inaudible] traditional
territories
in the southern Colombia
[foreign work].
So I've been on that radio
like a month-and-a-half before,
and [foreign words] radio which
reaches not just the community,
but spills over into the
local city of [foreign words].
And, again, it's an important
channel, just like [inaudible]
and all the other wonderful
[inaudible] we've heard about today
of really getting the
lowdown, the real story
on what's happening
in our communities.
And these land occupations
that were happening
in traditional territory
are to get back land
that the government has
already promised to return
through constitutional recognition
of Indigenous Territories
and through specific agreements.
And Efigenia was just covering the
land recovery and she was shot.
So it's very sad that we
still have people who speak
out are putting themselves in a
spotlight and in the frontlines
and endangering their lives.
So there's a lot at stake here.
People are willing to do
anything to get the message
out when it's about survival.
So local Indigenous radio is very
important for local organizing,
but increasingly we have a
migration to urban centers
and those urban centers are not
always in our own countries.
I, myself, migrated.
So I wanted to talk a little bit
about the other Indigenous voices
in the airspace or in the web space
right here in the United States.
And one of them is
called Kichwa Hatari.
Kichwa Hatari is Kichwa-language
radio based out of the Bronx.
And it's based out of
this wonderful basement
that Segundo Angamarca was able
to access and create a studio
and this became, along with
First Voices Indigenous Radio ,
the only Indigenous radio
programs out of New York City.
And First Voices Indigenous Radio
is actually a program that has been
on the air for a very long time
through the Pacifica Network run
by [inaudible] Ghost Horse.
And his is a global Indigenous
program, so I've often gone
to that radio to translate.
I've brought participants
from the Native American Film
and Video Festival who also bring
urgent stories from home to share.
And I interpret on the air.
So it's real interesting when
you have these collaborations
that allow us to hear what's
going on with our brothers
and sisters across the continent.
So Kichwa Hatari is kind of
a Latin American counterpart
to First Voices , and
it's become a native space.
And they welcome hip-hop artists,
whoever's visiting New York,
and it's multi-lingual.
It's primarily in Spanish
and Kichwa,
but they also welcome speakers
of the variance of Kichwa
from across the seven countries in
the Andes that speak the language,
but also if your [inaudible]
doesn't speak English,
then they'll translate into
Spanish or Kichwa on the air.
And this is broadcast
via [inaudible] stereo
on the Internet live, 8
o'clock at night on Fridays.
So Kichwa Hatari has come
to the Folklife Festival
and we've had a pop-up.
And they've been broadcasting
and teaching Kichwa
and playing Andean music
and that's the first image.
This was their stand out at the
Folklife Festival this summer.
So it can be done now with other
means, but we have to also look
at language, not just as an isolate,
something that is spoken by a group
of people in a remote region.
Kichwa is bringing people together.
There's the diaspora of
migrants from the Andean area
and from the Amazonian
areas in Latin America.
And they're coming together
because of the use of the language
through the radio program.
That's been a really
beautiful initiative.
And then also in another way
connecting some of the topics
that we've just heard today.
I think scholarship
is really important.
We have these archives that are
scattered, but it's the scholars
who find out and sometimes
link them together
and can help produce better metadata
so that we can actually
know what is where.
So I think that's one
thing that has to happen.
Everyone should -- all
these institutions --
it's wonderful that OU has done it
-- should look inward and say well,
what Native resources do I have,
and is it a special collection?
Is it scattered?
Is it even a collection?
Are the resources just
sitting there, right?
So that's something where NMAI, I
think, has a role to play in sort
of advising on sort of how
do we pull a magnet through
and just pull all the
Native resources together
and then start thinking
about tagging them
in ways that are easy to find.
I trolled the whole Folkways
and Folklife website.
But I found that a lot of
resources have the original names.
For instance, I couldn't
find [foreign words],
but I found Tarascan.
So the sort of renaming, adding
that into the metadata is important
to find your ancestors
in the archives.
So I think that's an
important point, too.
And the names of the
languages have also changed.
As we use the languages of our
own creation and not the names
that other people gave our
people or our languages.
So this is [inaudible] I wanted
to share, too, which is --
there's a Mapuche scholar
who's the head
of the Native Studies
Program now at Austin, Texas.
And he's been working with
a radio show in Santiago,
Chile, called Wixage Anay .
It means wake up, get up.
And it's been broadcast
continually, weekly,
since 1993 in Santiago, Chile.
It was actually founded in '93.
And it's broadcast in
Spanish and Mapuzungun.
And the idea was to reach the
Mapuche audiences that have migrated
to the city where they are
becoming assimilated and dispersed.
So this is a radio show that really
has, again, [foreign word] Hatari,
brought together communities
that are diasporized.
Brought them together
through the language.
And some people have even
revitalized the language
by listening to the show because
it's completely bilingual, right?
So they have actually, since they've
been recording steadily for 24 years
on cassette, right,
they have an archive.
And they've started a GoFundMe
campaign to raise $6000
that they need just to build
a safe space for this archive.
And they were working in
different radio stations.
They didn't have their own station,
so they had like a feminist
radio station sponsor them.
Then somebody got a job at another
one; they'd move over there.
They've been on Christian radios.
I mean, they've just been wherever
they can be to broadcast, right?
So I wanted to show this video.
How do I do the notes?
>> Jenni Monet: You want
to get out of Notes?
>> Amalia Cordova: I
want to see my notes.
I want to see this link.
>> Jenni Monet: All right.
Can I help?
>> Amalia Cordova: Yeah.
I think that's the --
>> Jenni Monet: I don't know how
to do how Melissa got her notes.
>> Amalia Cordova: I
think it's presenter.
>> Jenni Monet: But I
think you can get --
>> Amalia Cordova: There.
Okay. That's the Facebook.
Thank you.
>> Jenni Monet: There.
>> Amalia Cordova: Okay.
Can I click on that?
>> Jenni Monet: Yeah.
>> Amalia Cordova: Will it come up?
I have to copy it.
>> Jenni Monet: And
then take [inaudible].
And it's three minutes, right?
>> Amalia Cordova: Yes.
All right.
That's it.
>> Hello. I am Luis [foreign words].
Now I have the honor to be in
the home of [foreign words]
in [foreign words], and their family
here in [foreign words] District
in Santiago, the capital
city of Chile.
And this is a moment for all
of us to thank all of you
who have made contributions,
significant contributions,
to help the [foreign words]
Radio Show, which I --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> Hello, everyone.
My name is [foreign words] and we
are so grateful for your cooperation
and contribution to this
show, radio program.
Your cooperation is very important
for us to support our radio program
which is called [foreign words].
Thank you.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> Alysa [speaking in foreign
language] they have expressed their
gratitude to all of you for your
contribution here in their home.
Something else you want to add
about what Alysa mentioned,
and speak [inaudible].
>> Jenni Monet: All
right, thank you.
It's just 10:40, and maybe
we can share the link.
It's on Facebook.
It's this -- or their Kickstarter.
>> Amalia Cordova: It's a GoFundMe.
>> Jenni Monet: It's a GoFundMe.
Okay. We can find them there.
I thank you so much,
Amalia [applause].
I really appreciate
your contribution.
And to the panel for just
having great patience
with the technical,
technicalities here.
And to you, our audience.
Thank you so much for being here.
I'm sure some of the panelists are
here for questions if you have them.
Unfortunately, due to our delay,
we did not have time
to make time for Q&A.
But I think people --
>> We have five minutes.
>> Jenni Monet: We
have five minutes?
>> Yeah.
>> Jenni Monet: Oh,
we have five minutes.
Okay. Oh, I thought that
the panel ended at 10:40.
Okay, we have five minutes.
So if there is a question
from the audience
to any one of the panelists.
Yes, in the back, please.
>> [Inaudible] with the
preservation of broadcast,
is there a general belief that
there are recordings that exist
around the [inaudible] that one
might actually find some kind
of concentrated effort
remains to do the search?
>> Jenni Monet: So the question
is in terms of broadcast.
Is there a searchability --
>> Yeah.
>> Jenni Monet: -- protocol?
>> Is there a belief that
there are recordings that exist
that couldn't be found in
potentially [inaudible] --
>> Jenni Monet: Absolutely.
>> -- in native [inaudible]?
>> Jenni Monet: Yeah.
Hmm.
>> Or is there a general belief
that too much [inaudible]
necessarily lost [inaudible]?
>> Jenni Monet: Lina.
>> Lina Ortega Melissa Begay: Yes, I
do believe that there are recordings
that exist that need to be found.
I don't know that there's a whole
lot of them as far as the Indians,
where Indians or a
radio program goes.
But it was an option
for participants
to request a recording,
to request a tape.
And so I'm sure that they did.
And one of the things that I hope
the exhibit will accomplish is
to give us a forum for reaching out
more to the communities of the state
to identify the photographs, to
help us develop better descriptions
of the content, and
then also to identify
if there are other tapes
that exist out there.
OU does have an NEH-funded
grant right now that has to do
with preserving music recordings.
So it's not talking radio.
And they have not had a lot of
response to their surveys, you know,
asking people what are the
issues with preserving some
of your recordings that you have.
So that's a different project,
but they're kind of related.
I could talk to you more
at length if you want to.
Yeah.
>> Jenni Monet: Yes, please.
>> Why don't you choose in terms
of recordings or other kinds
of cultural artifacts that would
touch the [inaudible] in terms
of what other people
should have access to?
You know, sometimes very
particularly usages --
>> Lina Ortega Melissa
Begay: Oh, sure.
>> Jenni Monet: Well, I think
Lina touched on some of that, too,
with her presentation in sort of
the ceremonies that were documented
and really having that
kind of insight
about what you actually
are coming across.
Anyone on the - want
to speak to that?
>> Simon Moya-Smith: I know I was
-- if we're talking about like even
like language preservation.
Anything like Rosetta Stone
who's making the money off that.
You know. I mean, when I go into
a store and I see Rosetta Stone,
and it's an indigenous language,
and I'm like who gave
you permission, you know?
Or did you do that on
your own, you know?
And it's just like we see with
like our Inipi ceremonies,
our sweat lodges, and that you
can see people charging $70 to go.
And there was that, a
couple of years ago,
where he killed a bunch of people.
One guy did.
So, I mean, it's about
being responsible.
But the problem is
when it's our things,
people think they can just take
them, whether if our language,
our ceremonies, everything.
It's -- but they can't.
And we're trying to
push back against that.
So, yeah, there's a
level of responsibility,
but there is that sense of
privilege that I can just take this
and do what I want with it.
>> There was a presentation
yesterday by the [inaudible] people,
and they seem to have
created a space
where things can be
annotated and be searchable.
But at the same time
restricted to [inaudible].
>> Michael Pahn: Yeah.
I think you're touching on the
concept of cultural sensitivity
of like traditional knowledge
systems and, you know,
a place like a university
or a museum, you know.
In order to be responsible
stewards of materials we have
to be responsive to those
kinds of community concerns.
And it can be really complicated.
I mean there are thousands of Native
communities throughout the Americas,
and, you know, there isn't
a single Native America.
There are hundreds of
tribes and communities
that believe different things.
>> Jenni Monet: That's right.
>> Michael Pahn: I think that the --
maybe where this isn't as quite
as big an issue with radio is just
that it's been broadcast
in the first place.
I think a lot of people are
very sensitive to what goes
out to a broad audience
and what doesn't.
Now, that is -- those attitudes
have changed over time.
Maybe in the 1940s
people, even Native people,
weren't as necessarily
concerned about that.
But I think increasingly
that's something
that people are really aware of.
>> Amalia Cordova: And I
would add really briefly
that that's why we have
organizations like the Association
for Tribal Libraries,
Archives, and Museums,
who are probably working
specifically on those topics.
>> Jenni Monet: Thank you,
Amalia and Michael, for that.
>> Amalia Cordova:
There's one last question.
>> Simon Moya-Smith:
There's a question.
>> Jenni Monet: Okay, quickly.
>> I'm a native from Colombia,
South America, but I live in Texas.
And I'm very glad to hear
that this kind of conversation
and I am [inaudible] so
much of the -- what you say.
I would like many more people to
have the opportunity to hear this.
It breaks my heart
to see empty chairs.
[Inaudible] reservation is not
only impending [inaudible].
It's of the mind, especially
of the young.
If we don't have some adults who
are interested in seeing this type
of problem say -- I would say
many high schools in Texas
and many other places will
be curious to be in a place
like this that represents so much.
And to hear some of the voices that
you have, just the preservation
of the brain, the heart,
and a people.
>> Simon Moya-Smith: Right on.
>> Thank you.
Muchas gracias.
>> Jenni Monet: Thank you.
And thank you everyone.
I'm sure some of the
panelists are here
for your questions if
you'd like to speak.
Thank you [applause].
Thank you so very much for --
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.